another year without the postseason your  God or Dalai Lama or whatever I don't  know I'm still searching please show me  the way  Jordy Nelson now I hope you weren't  trying to tank tanking is a sin no but  sometimes I wish I was never even  drafted at all hmm that's an idea what  do you think Vince Lombardi okay I agree  you've never been drafted hey my legs  stopped hurting what I'm 49 years old  and I'm still the quarterback about  patterns  [Music]  without you brett favre wouldn't leave  the packers having won a game in ten  years state farms shut down nobody was  here to discount double check  the Bears won that 2010 NFC championship  I'm Jay Cutler and I never give up hey  hey watch subscribe to this channel and  rot your brain with more episodes  YouTube it's a distraction coach Coach  coach wait coach coach hey wait coach  coach goes